des toiles d'un bon dîner qui chante ce
soir quand on fermer les yeux quand il
faisait grève toujours le même hymne
était le roi tiff le ridicule s'il leur
vin
et le réveil à personne le roi avait
déjà quitté sans trop et tu te lèves
fini ton rêve passer une bonne image et
fait exécuter mon travail pour une année
je vais demander une disponibilité à mes
employeurs d'une année et je suis parti
comme ça que mon fils j'ai tout investi
dans la roulotte la chaîne la roulotte
et le cheval en fête
comment l'idée m'est venue est l'origine
de la roulotte j'en sais trop rien je
crois que ça doit correspondre à à vous
savez quand on dit toujours au genou
ras-le-bol le jeu est tout petit et je
vais partir et puis ce but et puis juste
pour mon travail
et puis je veux partir je sais pas
comment exactement mais je vais partir
ça correspond à 1 place à la seule
différence que ce cette phrase là bas on
est allé enfin je suis allé avec la
neige jusqu'au bout
ya toujours des déceptions je crois dans
les rapports avec les gens tous les gens
ne sont pas roses et bleus prend la
température d'un village come on come on
prend la température d'un robinet avec
le mélangeur d'eau chaude et d'eau
froide alors quelquefois c'est trop
chaud quelques fois ces pros froid
quelques pensées bouillante
quand on arrive il peut y avoir un
sourire à l'entrée du village je ne sais
pas un mauvais accueil sur la place du
village et puis des quolibets à la fin
donc rien n'est défini tout d'abord on
croit que c'est sans [ __ ] quand
on vient c'est à dire que bombe à la
roulotte à la mauvaise réputation du
voleur de poules et or je ne vole pas de
poulet ne serait ce que parce qu'il faut
les fumer et d'autre part on ferme les
volets puis on se barricade derrière
celui qu'est ce que c'est ça ensuite il
ya la deuxième réaction la réaction qui
est il n'y a pas de femmes alors ça ça
parait vraiment suspect allons regarder
évidemment l'intérieur de la roulotte on
cherche la femme
je crois que pour pallier à toute
question un peu curiosité disons je dis
que j'ai eu
j'ai eu un accouchement difficile alors
soit ça fait rire alors les gens sont
sympas soit alors ça les met encore dans
un bain de de doute ça encore plus grand
alors là évidemment je rigole bien
il reste bien
tam est un chapon farci
oui mais s'en fait pas
avi
on a tout investi là-dedans et on a
investi 2000 francs dans le spectacle
puisque nous faisons un petit spectacle
avec lionel un spectacle que j'ai écrit
à base de masques de chansons qui nous
permet de continuer à vivre de manger de
donner à manger à hector à peypin le
chien et nous acheter un peu tout ce
qu'il nous faut c'est à dire que la
viabilité
nous dépendons complètement de la
population d'ailleurs que nous ne sommes
pas attendu quelque part alors
évidemment il ya bons et mauvais contact
quelquefois ça dépend des régions avec
notre histoire d'un petit garçon qui
ferait tout savoir et qui avaient ou non
cotillons cas c'est rigolo que mon petit
et 10 mois que la fête qu'est ce que tu
vas faire dans cette histoire que tu
arrives style et surtout qui va tu
rencontré et coûteux dans un petit
instant nous avons rendez vous je le
vois qui se l'est bonjour monsieur le
vent
une fois qu'on est acceptée dans un
village une fois que l'on a joué notre
spectacle une fois que les gens ont vu
l'enfant jouer dans le spectacle le
démaquillage de maquillage la roulotte
et surtout quand ils ont ils ont pu voir
que que disons jeu je ne spécule pas sur
la bonne foi des gens alors dès qu'ils
sentent ce rapport là il n'y a aucune
espèce de problème je suis acceptée dans
un village comme une comme personne
salut vision du drôlement chouette mais
tu m'a tout l'air de partir en voyage
toit où vas-tu desservis c'est curieux
moi j'en ai jamais entendu parler ça
doit être tout petit quand même des
existe près ce que tu me dis ça parce
que quoi
wen
j'ai linge de voir de plus près j'ai
fait mes bagages et je suive un trait en
route pour desservir
c'est là bas que tout est si facile de 3
en route pour desservir un avec toi d'un
petit patron tu sais mais alors lé bon
bah histoire de coty moins desservis au
meeting
ben alors en route pour desservir
c'est là bas peut tout est spacieux 1
il aurait été peut-être plus simple si
j'avais été chapeauté soit par une
maison de d'apéritif ou par une radio
par une télévision quelconque ou par un
magazine ce que l'on m'a proposé
d'ailleurs mais à ce moment là les
rapports de l' aventure n'aurait plus
été les mêmes à dire que l'on mourait
attendu on m'aurait dit ah oui si le
bonhomme d'un tel que l'on attend que
l'on tend lui à la radio la télévision
et puis on va bien le recevoir parce que
ça peut nous apporter quelque chose dont
ces culation h préfère à ce moment-là
courir la réelle aventure pourquoi
partir sur les routes s'il ya quelqu'un
qui vous attendent donc l'aventuré
véritable réside d'abord dans les
hangars de man
les lits
blais
les mendiants et toujours le demandeur
j'ai toujours besoin de quelque chose je
ne suis je ne suis jamais autonome que
je mendie de l'eau
moi quand je dois m'arrêter par exemple
avec la roulotte je m'arrête je détale
de cheval lui donne à manger et je
demande la permission après je peux pas
demander la permission à fait je peux
pas laisser un cheval comme ça est
demandé est ce que vous voudriez bien
que non ce que les gens ne sont pas là
le cheval je peux pas le laisser tout
seul quand même puisqu'ils à l'enfant
qui est là je fais d'abord tout et je
demande après j'ai dû attendre vraiment
que la roulotte pour pour avoir une eau
le mot n'est pas trop fort une communion
ont presque avec halak hector et avec
tous les chevaux maintenant les zones
autonomes tout doux
ça fait maintenant quelques petits mois
que l'on roule sur la route avec
lyonnais je me rendais pas compte à quel
point les gens étaient adorables et à
quel point les eaux traitées et et
imbécile dire qu'il ya une échelle de
capacité dans le bipède qui m'étonne
c'est à dire qu'il ya une palette que
j'ignorais
je m'en serais rat est un petit bout
dans trois siècles dans un an
dans la mer on chez les oiseaux dans un
monde différent des toiles ou du
coquelicot
c'est la fin de notre histoire
continuons notre chemin salut tout le
monde au revoir dernier refrain
un jour on se reverra
où l'on ne se reverra peindre c'était un
petit coup de vieux
qu'elle en oublie que l'on lui il y a
vraiment un monde totalement différent
entre le milieu rural et le milieu
citadin la libération de la femme par
exemple on en parle beaucoup ça n'existe
absolument pas lié toujours la noc
entend panne il ya toujours la notion du
du maître la notion de la femme
la notion du propriétaire et là moi
c'est une chose que j'ignorais encore un
peu et puis maintenant moi je fais
connaissance avec ça et surtout je joue
avec avec ses rapports là je vais vous
demander s'il était possible de me
mettre pour la nuit si si si ça vous
gêne pas parce que parce que j'étais
allé chez une dame qui était avant un
peu plus bas sur la route
et puis qui m'a dit que je pouvais pas
rester là j'étais absolument impossible
que je devais voir la patronne qui
étaient ici elle n'est pas là pour le
moment bon écoutez ce que je vais faire
d'une façon parce que je n'ai pas le
choix on ne peut pas repartir parce que
ce que je vais me mettre là je vais dit
que le cheval et puis je vais attendre
la patronne elle vient vers quelle heure
à peu près là vous tournez pas là
maintenant il
continuons notre chemin salut tout le
monde vous
dernier refrain un jour on se reverra
où l'on me ce revers a peint des tout
petits bouts de vie que l'on n'oublie si
je chante les v10 ou si vous ne me
croyez pas la vie sera toute grise comme
des canons comme des soldats
c'est la fin de notre histoire
continuons notre chemin salut tout le
monde
revois dernier refrain un jour se
refaire
où l'on ne se reverra pain c'est est un
petit bout de vie que l'on dit que l'on
que non